alors cette semaine rien sur la
politique Thierry parce que la semaine
dernière et j'ai fait Robert Ménard et
trop d'emmerde voilà donc
voici Tom villa Monster
[Applaudissements]
qui arrive viens voir les comédiens
les musiciens c'est pour nos invités
évidemment voilà les comédiens sont
Denes les magiciens Éric Antoine les
non à vous de nous dire si vous jouez du
piano ou de la flûte
Éric Antoine on écrit ensemble des
petites bêtises des fois pour Michel
Drucker Michel si tu nous regardes on
t'embrasse et puis je tenais à dévoiler
ce soir une sorte de petit secret la
cantine de Michel Drucker est beaucoup
trop petite au Studio Gabriel et du coup
il nous est déjà arrivé avec Eric de
manger de la piémontaise sur le canapé
de Vivement Dimanche voilà on peut faire
un zoom ou pas donc voilà je tiens à
m'excuser auprès de Michel les miettes
de pain c'était nous par contre les
croûtes c'était chez l'un alors
[Applaudissements]
on se connaît un petit peu on a partagé
la même loge à l'Olympia
et Nathalie koscius alors là je vous
sens un petit peu tendu vous inquiétez
pas j'ai aucune photo de nous deux par
contre j'ai tout filmé je t'enverrai la
vidéo alors
Eric Antoine Eric vous êtes le plus
grand invité de Salut les Terriens cette
saison 2 m 07 alors vous n'êtes pas là
en invité du samedi 20h entre la femme à
barbe et l'aveugle qui a fait le tour du
monde non non
c'est impressionnant mais c'est ça veut
dire que même assis vous êtes encore
plus grand que Manuel Valls et puis vous
êtes magicien et humoriste un peu comme
jamais le bon sauf que lui de Jamel il
fait toujours le même tour il fait
disparaître sa main dans sa poche ça
c'est super
[Applaudissements]
plus pourquoi
faire un petit tour à Nathalie
quelque chose c'est vrai
c'est le tour où tu fais disparaître son
passé Sarkozy tout
fait de la magie mais pas des miracles
non
mais oui
ils sont Dedienne Vincent Dedienne vous
êtes humoriste et vous êtes originaire
de Macron alors je vais pas me moquer de
Macron Thierry déjà parce que Vincent le
fait très bien sur scène et puis surtout
non mais c'est vrai dans ton spectacle
et tout moi je suis originaire
Roissy-en-Brie en Seine-et-Marne
et honnêtement un mec de Roissy-en-Brie
qui se moquerait d'un mec de Macron ça
le fait pas c'est un peu comme le cancer
qui se moquerait du sida c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai à la fin est globalement
la même mais quitte à mourir autant se
marrer un petit peu avant aux parents
ont découvert vous étiez gay en venant
vous voir sur scène c'est quand même la
double peine chérie notre fils est gay
en plus il est intermittent
c'est pas grave c'est pas un drame et
tout c'est vrai que vos parents ça
aurait pu être plus graves ils auraient
pu découvrir je sais pas comme les
parents de Titeuf que vous étiez pas
drôle et devant
bonsoir alors cette semaine rien sur la
politique Thierry parce que la semaine
dernière j'ai fait Robert Ménard et trop
d'emmerde voilà donc il t'aime beaucoup
Robert j'irai pas en vacances à Béziers
donc voilà donc en tout cas je parlerai
pas de vos idées pas de votre vie privée
donc NKM vous êtes né un 14 mai et ce
soir vous êtes à Salut les Terriens
voilà si ça va trop loin dites le
moisiri
lors de l'élection régionale vous avez
vous aviez voulu un petit peu soutenir
Valérie Pécresse dans l'Essonne et vous
avez fait la rime suivante Pécresse
c'est moins de stress c'est bien oui
c'est non non mais pourquoi pas pourquoi
on dit que trouver des slogans c'est un
métier avec Fillon vous avez quoi
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson toujours pas voulu vous
poser
Eric Antoine
Eric vous avez été jury dans le
l'émission La France a un incroyable
talent qu'elle tourne vous a le plus
bluffé c'est le mec qui peint avec son
zizi ou le maquillage d'Hélène Segara
Joker et je félicite Thierry de ne pas
avoir posé cette question voilà moi j'ai
refusé j'aime trop Hélène il y a trop de
gens qui l'aiment d'ailleurs
Nathalie koscio Morizet le j'ai lu dans
une interview que le premier geste que
vous faites le matin vous le vend c'est
d'ouvrir en grand votre fenêtre vous
avez d'autres points communs avec Mike
Brant
et pour terminer Vincent Dedienne et
Vincent vous avez pas comment on dise
que vous faites du one man show mais
plutôt du seul en scène est-ce que c'est
pareil pour tout par exemple vous dites
pas un fils fucking mais un point dans
les fesses
et celle là il faut répondre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu